[Music]
we all know justin theroux is a super
busy actor and writer so when he wants
to unwind with his famous guy friends
like Will Arnett he said they actually
stay in and play call of duty and we
played that game together and we kill
each other with the headsets and stuff
like all things the headsets were
communicating like the actor opened up
about his favorite hobby on Thursdays
Late Late Show it's safe to say his wife
Jennifer Aniston won't be participating
anytime soon she doesn't understand it
yeah she thinks what she thinks she is I
have to count your girls going girls
nights and so you gotta kind of pitch it
is like oh by the way guys are getting
together tonight she's like oh cool
where you going I'm like to my office
you must cease blood going across the
screen like this and she doesn't
understand that I'm actually having a
brozen et spoke with sorrow about his
videogame obsession in 2015 how intense
is the habit um it was problematic
earlier on I learned to get it under
control a little bit does Jen ever play
with you laughs Jen does not put it
again she's nice enough to let me go
away for a couple hours a couple times a
week and play
you